we're hearing now from johnny depp's
attorney camille vasquez this is her
first sit-down interview since depp and
amber heard filed motions to appeal in
their legal battle now last week heard
notified of virginia court that she will
appeal the more than 10.3 million
settlement she was ordered to pay her
ex-husband
depp's legal team also filed an appeal
to overturn a single count of defamation
decided in herd's favor ordering depth
to pay amber heard two million dollars
vasquez told us what prompted depp's
decision to appeal
last week we heard that amber heard was
going to appeal the verdict what did you
think when you heard that what was your
reaction it was expected i mean she's
indicated
since the day she lost the trial that
she was going to appeal do you have to
plan a strategy to
to respond to that absolutely and we did
mr depp ended up filing his own appeal
so that the court could have the full
record and you know she insists on
continuing to litigate this matter
we have to protect our clients interests
yeah we've heard that it's not about the
money it's time for healing and time to
move on which was the message that he
sent but how do you heal and move on
when both sides are still in court
arguing it's pretty standard legal
procedure we just are hopeful that the
court will uphold the verdict which we
think was the right verdict and allow
both parties to to move on so is it safe
to say that if she hadn't appealed you
all would not have appealed either you
would have moved on yes
is that a fair statement that's a very
fair statement
yeah she said it's not a matter because
i said it sounds a little tit for touch
she goes nope this is a legal strategy
we reached out to amber hurd and her
legal team to speak with us about their
appeal they told us that they're not
commenting at this time we're going to
have more from our interview with
camille vasquez in our next hour
including the young team that they put
together to win this case it's very
interesting to see the because most of
these people were under the age of 40
under the age of 35 actually you know
camille has gotten a lot of the
attention out of the spotlight because
she was so what people call dazzling a
courtroom they said it's a textbook case
how she handled herself but she says it
wasn't just me we had a lot of people
working behind the scenes and i think
you'll be surprised to see how young
these people were and what they did i'm
looking forward to being surprised about
that gail thank you very much for that